from time to time i like to get out of
the studio to hang out with our guests
feel the sunshine and fresh air
we call these segments drive interviews
[Music]
all right you'll never guess who showed
up and in what car at the outdoor
theater the other day take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey you what's up
i love your car i love your car
you win you brought kit this is amazing
one of my first cars that i ever got i
named kit it was a cadillac xlr was
black it was like
like a sport true sports car and i was
like his name shall be kit
kit's amazing you know the most amazing
thing about kit is that
today kit is still relevant maybe after
36
40 years later everything is exactly
what we came up with back in the day
it's weird
the cars talk yeah the cars drive
themselves they park
yeah that's amazing
[Music]
speaking of knight rider though there
were a lot of like stunts did you do
any of this done yeah yeah well i did i
got really good at driving
because i wanted to and the reverse 180
is
i could teach you at about five minutes
we had no cgi and we did everything of
the seat of our pants
and the best part about it was they
would have 40 guys out there paid
not to kill me and they would say action
nightmare
and i just go woohoo and i just do a
wd-40 and spray the wheels
and spin out spin through and go through
and then you got paid for that
can you believe it that's amazing it's
incredible
would you ever do a reboot there's a
reboot in the making
so we'll see what happens yeah
[Music]
i actually heard there was a hoff
auction yeah we had an auction auction
you know i went to the half auction was
like going to my funeral it was like
going to a different
a different time you know it's best just
to get rid of this stuff
sell it give the money to charity which
i gave a lot of money to
the global mobility company which is
makes children walk it has
creates wheelchairs for them yeah i
still have got like four or five
auctions left
i heard that one of your most prized
possessions it
involves spongebob yeah one of my prized
possessions in my house
is a 13 and a half foot 750 pound
version of david hasselhoff
more like i feel like you should just
put it right as you enter your home
[Laughter]
i was thinking that would be
amazing you have a heavy metal album
coming out i did a heavy metal song you
know called through the night
that's so cool you do what's in front of
you yeah i just go with the flow kelly
yeah i mean the phone didn't ring for 10
years now the phone's ringing oh my gosh
that's awesome
i just wanted to tell you i love your
show and my kids love your show and
everybody loves it because you're honest
because you tell the truth and because
you're fun
you know oh thank you thank you i'm too
lazy to be a liar or
anything else i'm just
doomy and if you like it cool if you
don't that's cool yeah
yeah well thank you for doing the show
you're welcome honey
god bless all right later
all right so is it true that you have a
new project in germany
i do i have a show uh series and uh it's
about my time behind
the berlin wall and it's kind of like
fact or fiction
and we start shooting in august and it's
going to be
and mostly in english but a little bit
of german and it's going to be
really exciting oh my god it sounds
amazing the story is incredible and
just in real life so i can't imagine it
being on film yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this
box forever